okay so this is happen you're gonna suck
it up there we go and we're gonna go to
dinner okay hey please call security
every day for eight years I have brought
pepper spray into this office to protect
myself and my fellow employees and every
day for eight years people have laughed
at me well who's laughing now
hey Jimmy Brogan Thanks for meeting me
welcome to the schvitz kid most
comfortable place on earth it's like
crawling back into your mother is that
something people want to do would you
want to talk to me about ah
so I read those quotes you sent me and
you wrote them so good thing is I know I
hit it incredibly well but I was pretty
drunk when I said that stuff so any
chance you wouldn't print it well you
said you were going on the record I was
clearly not in control maybe you should
learn to handle your Brown yeah look you
know that I think you're like the number
one hero of the 20th century but I kind
of feel like you're being unfair you
feel like listen there Suzanne Somers
over here talk like a man all right I
will talk like a man you got me drunk it
took advantage of me oh come on
God I'm asking you nicely please don't
print the quotes and I'm telling you
nicely I'm printing them no you're not
what are you gonna do about it
hey how'd it go broken perfect except I
punched him in the face made everything
a billion times worse what
[Music]
leslie knope here comes the booth all
dressed and boo Leslie Knope boo boo boo
dude what are you doing I'm being
awesome boo boo Leslie be my friend I
don't think you understand what a bad
idea this is I don't think you
understand that I would have got a cut
of that new paunch burger if she hadn't
screwed everything up so sorry guys this
wedding is canceled cuz the bride is a
bee hole hey check this out
Steve stick boring shooters oh my god
where'd you even get a stink bomb Amazon
baby that's how you are looking at a
Prime customer everybody two days free
shipping for this guy let's get this
party started with another one game oh
it's terrible Jerry you do the wedding
who cares come on man just go home who's
gonna make me it's your wedding day I'll
handle this here comes the bride time to
go sir
no the hell man she touched me I'll give
you that one but if you do it again if I
do what again what kick your ass now you
like you want me to do the best wedding
ever
Kelly how are you I heard that the
longest me Oh welcome to my convenience
store would you like some gooey gobby I
have some very delicious Googie Googie
only 99 cents plus tax
try my Googie Googie try my
cookie-cookie
try my cookie-cookie time
oh right all right yes
that was great she gets it
now she knows what it's like to be a
minority we needed to deal with what's
bothering you oh please come into my
room see you're angry at me and you're
not talking about it and I'm gonna beat
you up until you do because I'm mature
wait stop it I grew up with five
brothers and we fought using the dryer
method which was yelling wrestling
crying followed by lots of hugs and then
more wrestling but the fun kind and then
crying when the fun kind of wrestling
got out of hand
um can you let me go until you tell me
what's wrong
[Music]
I need to get more tips all right gum
come on walk none this is a pacifist
protest had enough you need to let go of
me come on yeah nice yeah oh my god Andy
I am so sorry
Oh psyche blood capsules what yeah I
wanted to shock you into expressing your
anger and that way my nose is broken
I argue with the hospital feel good yeah
yep hello Peralta what is the deal with
you and this second-rate
pizza joint this place is a Brooklyn
institution and I'm here because you
think Sal did it and you're wrong he did
do it how is in financial trouble he has
no alibi and in cases of arson the owner
always did it what's going on sir what's
going on is it Peralta his screw with me
for the last time and now he's gonna pay
oh you know what foon anytime you want
to give
[Music]
don't tell me what to tell people what
to do will make me not do it tough guy
I apologize marshal boon for detective
Peralta's actions something I find
myself doing quite frequently in my
defense I was the only one saying we
should stop hitting hey everybody he's
not in the men's room although the seat
was warmed so we may have just missed
him my money's on Japan it's not a fight
what other outcome could there be
Michel could win Wow can it back why
can't you just agree with me sometimes
am I scared of getting in the face no
everyday weirdos paid dominatrixes
hundreds of dollars for that very
privilege
I'm scared I'm gonna love it do this
it's okay guys I can handle this
nobody can go home we're here for the
show Michel you're just a bunch of
lawyers are you eating popcorn almost no
calories you ready yes you have to keep
your hands down I know okay all right Oh
God Michel yes hands down put your hands
in your pocket okay
pam-pam I'm really sorry I'm sorry
what are you sorry for so many things I
don't know it's hard to choose how about
for dating my mom
maybe it's dumping her on her birthday
yes okay just
don't ever date a member of my family
again
so the reckon your mom came on to me
holy crap are you okay no you're okay
yeah better no you were right wait why
are you limping I don't know let's get
some raw meat on that face I've got a
chicken in the freezer upstairs as I
watched Pam's big strong hand coming
toward my face I saw my entire life
flash before my eyes
and guess what I have four kids and I
have a hover car and hover house and my
wife is a runner and it shows and Pam
and Jim are my best friends and our kids
play together and I am happy I'm rich
and I never die it doesn't sound like
much but it's enough
you